hello my name is beau Carnes and I'm
with freak ok org this is a complete CSS
course or cascading style sheets CSS is
something you use to style websites or
style HTML so before you watch this
course you should have some familiarity
with HTML you can learn HTML through the
free HTML curriculum at freak ok org or
you can check out the video course that
I link to in the description this whole
CSS course follows along with the CSS
curriculum at freak ok org so when you
hear me talk about challenges or
completing challenges I'm talking about
the challenges as part of that
curriculum however it's a standalone
video so you don't have to go through
the curriculum to get value out of this
course but if you want to you can go
through that curriculum as well I have
the link to the free code camp
org CSS curriculum in the description
after you finish this course you may
want to try out some CSS projects so I
have a link to a playlist with a bunch
of CSS projects you can do a write in
the description and then after you
master CSS and HTML it may be good to
try out JavaScript so I have a link to a
JavaScript course also in the
description so let's get started
in this challenge we're going to talk
about inline styles inline styles are
where you style something right on the
element that you want to effect so if I
put my mouse on this P tag here I can
add a style to the PP AK by just using
style and then we're gonna put what the
style is going to be and we're gonna put
color blue so that would just make the
color that text blue but for this
challenge we're not going to style the P
tag we're gonna style the h2 so I'm
going to undo that and now I'm going to
add the style to this h2 tag and I'm
going to make the style where the color
is going to be thread just like that and
let's open up the browser and see what
that looks like okay you can see that
the text the title here is red
[Music]
in the last challenge we talked about
inline styles that's what this is here
now we're going to talk about a
different way to add styles using a
style block and you can see we use color
red there are actually hundreds of CSS
properties like color we're going to
eventually get to those but not quite
yet I'm going to show you the style
block so to make a style block just at
the beginning I can add the the tag
style and then we just need a closing
style block and now I can add all my
Styles between these two style tags so
let me give you an example if I wanted
to style all the paragraph tags I can
put a P and then I'm going to put a
curly brace and inside these two curly
braces I'm going to put color red now
this is going to style all the
paragraphs every time you see a P tag
like here here and all the P tags are
gonna now be red if we look in the
browser we can see what that's going to
look like so you can see look this
paragraph is red this paragraph is red
all the P tags have now changed the text
to read so for this challenge
we're going to take out the inline style
here and I'm going to add some style to
this block up here instead of styling P
tags we're gonna sell the h2 tags and
I'm going to make them all blue so I'm
going to put color blue
now let me open up the browser and we'll
see what that looks like if i refresh
and you can see the h2 is now blue
in the last challenge we learned about
styling tags like this all eight two
tags are blue in this challenge we're
talking about styling classes classes
are reusable styles that can be added to
HTML elements so to show that you're
styling a class you would put a dot in
front of it so I'm going to change the
state's h2 to dot blue text and if you
add this dot blue text this is only
going to style elements that have a
class of blue text so for instance for
this paragraph I'm going to add a class
and I'm going to put in blue text now
you can see I put a period up here but
you don't put a period down here the
period just means it's a class when
you're looking at your CSS your Styles
so if I open this in my browser and
refresh it we can see that this is now
blue right here we're gonna change this
up instead of making us a blue text it's
now going to say red text and this color
is going to become red I'm not going to
need this anymore because instead of
putting the class on the paragraph I'm
going to put the clasp on this h2 tag
it's going to be class red text and then
if I show that in the browser and
refresh you can see the title is red
what's great about classes is that they
allow you to use the same CSS styles on
multiple HTML elements so friends and
see how this has class read text I can
hand write X a class read text to any
element to make it read and that's what
we're gonna do in this challenge
so on the first P element right here
right up here I'm gonna add class equals
read text and when I open up the little
browser here you'll see that the title
is red and the first paragraph is red
just by adding the class to both
elements
there are hundreds of different CSS
properties we've only talked about color
so far but another one is font size
that's pretty self-explanatory it's
going to change the font size of an
element so for instance I can put font
size 30 pixels and now everything that
has the red text class will also be font
size 30 so if I look in here you can see
that this paragraph is a lot bigger now
we're going to change the font size of
paragraphs so I'll just remove what I
had here and I'm going to add another
style so right down here it's going to
be P and the font size is going to be 16
pixels so I'm gonna put 16 px and now if
I show the browser here we'll see that
all the paragraphs are 16 pixels that
we've just increased everything to 16
pixels for the paragraphs
you can set which font an element should
use by using the font family property
now you can use a type or style of font
like serif sans serif or mono space or
you can put in the exact font so in this
challenge we're gonna make all the P
elements mono space so right here I'm
going to put font family and then mono
space and if we just show this in the
browser and refresh you can see now we
have these this mono space font here
just like that
you can import fonts from different
websites a free library of web fonts
that you can use is google fonts they
have a lot of great fonts and that's
what we're going to do in this challenge
we're gonna see how to import google
fonts so if I just paste in some code up
here
this code comes directly from the Google
Fonts website and you can see it's the
font family lobster so I'm just about to
show you how to use that right in our
code here so what I'm going to do is for
the h2 element I'm going to at h2 here
and I'm at a font family of lobster now
that's all I really have to do for this
challenge if I wanted to I could add a
backup font that would be used just in
case the the Google font didn't load
like this I do a comma and then I can
put a generic font that's going to be
used if the specific font doesn't load
but we're not going to do that for this
I'm just going to open the browser and
see if it works and you can see we have
the lobster font right here
there are some default fonts available
in all browsers like mono space
serif and sans-serif you can see we're
using the mono space font right here so
when one font isn't available you can
tell the browser to degrade or default
to another font like one of these
default fonts like the monospace font
for example let's say we had the font
family in the font family we had held
that Helvetica so if I add Helvetica
right here and I can actually just make
a list of fonts right here so in font
family when you have a list here first
it tries the first font but if that
one's not available it will go to the
next font so when you're making a list
of font family font so you always want
the last one to be a generic font so you
know that if the browser can't get the
first font or the second fine it can
always get the the default font at the
end here so for this example for this
challenge we're gonna do that for the h2
tag so in this h2 tag we have lobster
let me delete Helvetica here and I'm
gonna make the default font mono space
now right now if I open up the browser
you're not gonna see anything different
you're gonna see a lobster here but if I
comment out the link to the Google Fonts
and now I'm going to refresh this and
you can see it's defaulted to the Mono
space just like that see so it couldn't
find Lobster so it defaulted to the mono
space font
CSS has a property called width that
controls an element's width this can
apply to almost any type of element like
an image or a div or a paragraph and
we're going to create a style that can
make a larger image so I'm going to
create this called larger image now
that's only going to apply to an element
with the class larger image and I'll put
width to be 500 pixels so if we have
anything with the class larger image it
will make it larger so I'm going to
actually add that to this image here I'm
going to put class equals larger image
so if we look in the browser here we
should see that the image is very big
right now for this challenge we're going
to make a smaller image so I'm just
going to actually just change this to
smaller and instead of 500 pixels we're
gonna make this 100 pixels and I have to
apply the smaller image class down here
so if I open the little browser and
refresh now it's just a tiny little cat
a cute little cat right there on our
page
CSS borders have properties like style
color and width let me show you an
example I'm going to actually make a
change to the h2 style here I'm going to
paste in some code you'll see border
color red border width five pixels
border-style:solid so when i refresh the
page here you'll see this red border
around the h2 tag I'm going to delete
this for right now because for this
challenge we're actually going to make a
thick green border so I'll just put it
right up at the top for now here and I
am going to make a new class called
thick green border and I'm just going to
actually paste in that same code from
before but the border color is now going
to be green and the border width can be
10 pixels and the border style will
still be solid here so now I'm going to
have to apply it to the image so right
now there's the class smaller image but
you can have two classes here I just put
a space and then I'm going to put thick
mean order so as long you just have a
space in between classes you can have
two classes so if i refresh here you'll
see the thick green border right around
there
you can see so far we have very sharp
corners around this image there's a
border radius property that we can use
to make that a little route more rounded
I'm going to add a new thing called
border radius and I'm going to set the
value to 10 pixels so if i refresh now
you can see we have rounded corners here
in addition to pixels so you can also
specify the border radius using a
percentage so instead of border radius
10 pixels I'm gonna change this to 50%
and if i refresh my page here you can
see it makes a circle
you can set an element's background
color with a property called
background color so here's an example
let's set the background color of the h2
element background color and I'm going
to change this to blue so if I open up
my browser we'll see that the background
is blue I'm gonna make a new class and
the new class is going to be called
silver background silver background and
you guessed it it's going to have a
silver background so I'm going to put
background color silver now remember I
also have to apply it somewhere I have
to make something use that class so for
this div an upper class equals silver
background now if i refresh here you can
see we have a silver background here we
don't need this background color blue so
I'll take that off here and refresh it
one more time and that's how it's
supposed to look
we've talked about styling specific
elements like this and then we've also
talked about styling classes you can
also style based on ID and ideas similar
to a class except each element is only
going to have one ID classes you can put
on a lot of different elements so let me
show you how to apply an ID to an
element if I just go down to this form
here and I'm just going to put IB equals
cat photo form and just like that it's
not going to change the appearance at
all because we haven't styled it yet but
now we can use the ID to add CSS styles
or we can reference it in JavaScript
in the last section we learned about IDs
now we're going to learn about styling
IDs I'll use this h2 as an example and
an ID of heading meter styling IDs it's
similar to when you're styling classes
but we are going to use in a hash mark
instead of a period so I'm gonna put
heading here let me format this little
better so you can see normally for the
class that start with a period for an ID
it's gonna start with a hash mark so I
am going to put color green now I want
to show you something so you can see
that this h2 has a class of red text and
a heading an ID of heading so we have
the red text and the heading so is it
going to be red or is it going to be
green well let's open the browser and
find out here you can see it is green
because CSS puts a higher priority to
IDs than classes and as a reminder you
should only have one ID per element we
already have the ID down here on the
form idea of camp photo form and so now
I'm going to change this instead of
heading it's gonna say cat photo form
and then for color we're gonna instead
of color green it's going to be
background color green and now I'm just
going to Reese refresh that and if I go
down here to the form you can see it's
green in the background
you may have already noticed this but
all HTML elements are essentially little
rectangles there are three properties
that control the space around each
element which is padding margin and
border we already talked about border
which you can see on here the padding is
the space around the text you can see
that the panning around this red text is
a little more than the padding around
the blue text the margin is the space
outside of the border that surrounds the
padding so in this task we are going to
change the padding we're going to change
the padding on the blue box to match
that of the red box so if we look down
here the padding on the blue box is 10
depending on the the red box is 20 so
we're just going to change this to 20
and then if i refresh my page here you
can see that these boxes are the same
size
an element's margin controls the amount
of space between an element's border and
the surrounding elements you can see
that there's greater margin on this red
box than the blue box so in this task
we're going to make sure that they're
both the same so I'm going to change the
margin of the blue box to match that of
the red box so you can see the margin is
20 on the red box so I'm just going to
set the blue box will also be 20 and
then if i refresh my page you can see
that they're the same
the reason why this red box is so big
right here is because it has negative
margin we're gonna make sure the blue
box is just as big as the red box by
giving the blue box negative margin as
well so I'm going to set this to
negative 15 so now the red box and the
blue box are both at negative 15 and if
i refresh the page now they're both the
same
as you can see in this red box each side
can have different amounts of padding
that's this code here padding top
padding right padding bottom padding
left we are going to use different
padding's for the different sides of the
blue box so I'm just going to copy this
code right here and then paste it down
here and now what we have to do for the
challenge is set the top and left to 40
so let's do 40 here and top and left are
already 40 and then the bottom and right
to 20 that's just the same as already is
so let me refresh and we're done
we already learned that you can set each
side of padding separately you can also
do the same thing for margin you can see
for this red box it has different margin
on each side we have margin top right
bottom left we're gonna do the same
thing for the blue box and I'm just
gonna copy this margin from the red box
and paste it in for the blue box and now
I'm just going to refresh my page
because we're done
previously we learned about padding top
padding right padding bottom and padding
left there is an easier way to do the
same thing and it's called clockwise
notation if I if we look at this browser
here and see the red box there's
actually a different padding on each
side so if you look at this padding here
see how these four numbers well the
first number is the top then the right
then the bottom then the left so we're
gonna do the same thing in the blue box
I'm going to start off by copying this
padding from the red box I'll paste it
into the blue box and this time the
padding top and left have to be 40 so
this one has to be 40 and then the last
one that's the left and the bottom and
right after be 20 those are the two
middle numbers so if I change those and
refresh we'll see that that they're both
kind of the same they're a little
different because this one has the 21st
and 40 and then this one has the 40 than
20 and that's it
we already learned about clockwise
notation for padding now we're going to
learn about it for margin it's basically
the same you can see this red box has a
different margin on each side so here's
the code here it's clockwise notation
there's four numbers the first is the
top right bottom and then left so you
can do all in one line instead of having
four different lines we're going to do
the same thing for the blue box so I'm
just going to start by copying this line
and to solve this challenge we're just
going to flip these two numbers around
because the 40 has to be this has to be
top and the 20 is going to be on the
right so if i refresh my page here you
can see that it has changed
we now know how to style classes so this
is an example of silent classes with a
dot before the class here and then you
can put the styles for the class and
then use style IDs with the hash mark
instead of a dot here will be a hash
mark now we're gonna learn how to use
attribute selectors to style elements
now this is a selector that matches and
styles elements with a specific
attribute value I'm going to show you an
example how to style something with a
type radio' so we can style it
everything with type radio' so let me
add that right up top here so what you
put brackets around and we're gonna do
that so we're gonna put the attribute
which is type and then we're going to
put the value which is radio so type
equals radio and we're gonna that's how
we're gonna select what we're styling so
here I'm just going to set the margin to
20 pixels so if we open up the browser
here now let me scroll down and we can
see that there is a margin around these
radio buttons of 20 pixels so now we're
gonna use the type attribute selector to
try to give the checkboxes a top margin
of 10 pixels and a bottom margin of 15
pixels so all I'm gonna do is so let's
go and look at the checkbox in the color
says type checkbox so we're gonna use
the same thing up here instead of type
radio' it's going to be type checkbox'
and then for the margin the top is going
to be 10 and the bottom is gonna be 15
so what I'm gonna do is do top if we do
the the clock one so the first number is
top the second number is right and this
can put zero pixels and then the third
number is bottom I'm going to put 15
pixels and then the fourth number is the
left which is zero pixels so if I just
refresh my page here
and the checkboxes are styled
so far we've been setting margins and
padding's using pixels pxc this example
negative 25 px or pixels these are
absolute types of lengths so absolute
types of lengths include like in4 inch
or mm millimeters these are all tied to
physical units of length but there's
also relative units of length such as
e/m and REM and these are relative to
another length value for example e/m is
based on the size of an element's font
and if you use it to set the font size
property itself it's relative to the
parents font size now we'll talk about
this a little more on the responsive web
design principle section but for now
we're gonna try setting some padding
using an e/m or M value so that's what
I'm going to show you now we're gonna
set the the class of the the red box
here we're gonna set the padding to an
e/m value so I'm gonna put padding and
it's just like how you would put pixels
but instead of doing px you just put the
M so this is going to be relative
depending on other things on the page if
I show the browser here now you'll see
this extra padding here around the red
box
every HTML page has a body element now
usually it'll be a more explicit you'll
see the the body tag round the page but
even if you don't see the body tag on
the page like in these examples it's
still there it's just hidden so we can
prove this by actually just styling the
body element so that's all we're gonna
do here I'm going to add a body here or
a body style and we're just gonna set
the background color to black and now if
i refresh my page you can see it turns
black this the whole page turns black
here
so we've seen that all pages have a body
element now CSS that stands for
cascading style sheets cascading means
anything that you apply to an upper
element goes down to any lower elements
or any elements that are inside other
elements so anything that you apply to
the body element will cascade or get be
inherited to all the other elements on
the page so let's see how that first I'm
going to create an h1 element and inside
the h1 element I'm going to say hello
world and now I'm going to style the
body element so we already have black
out color black I'm also gonna put color
green and I'm for the font family
I'll put it as mono space now let's open
up the browser and see what that looks
like okay look we have green mono spaced
font I didn't apply to the h1 tag I
applied to the body and then everything
else got that same style
sometimes your HTML elements will
receive multiple styles that conflict
with one another if you see on here this
h1 here
this body will apply it will cascade
down to the h1 to make the color green
but what if there is something else to
make this a different color what would
happen so what I'm gonna do is make a
new class it's gonna be called pink text
and I am going to make the color pink
and now I will apply the class to this
h1 tag so pink text so what do you think
is going to happen it has the color
green from here but also has the color
pink from here well let's open up the
browser and find out and it's pink the
way it works is it uses which every one
is more specific since this has the
class pink text and it doesn't start
with body or anything
the pink text is more specific than the
body because body is further up so
whatever one is closest to the actual
text is which style it will use
so we saw that this color pink overrides
the color green because pink text is
more specific than body what can we do
to overwrite this pink text here what if
I made another class like this I'm going
to just copy that and then paste it here
but instead of being pink text it's
going to be blue and the color is going
to be blue now I'm going to add another
class here remember to add two classes
you just put a space in between classes
I'm going to put blue text here so now
what's going to happen is going to be
pink or blue I'm just going to give you
one tip here that the order of the class
is here doesn't matter it doesn't matter
whether pink text or blue text comes
first so let's see what color the text
is going to be and you can see it's
going to be blue so the order that does
matter is the order that the Styles
declared in so if I just take this blue
text here I'm going to cut this and now
I'm going to just paste it right up here
and now if i refresh the page you'll see
that it's pink because it just depends
on what order this comes in here
so we saw they could override styles by
making things more specific pink text
the class overrides just styling the
body and then we saw you could override
styles by putting things lowering in the
styling section so this blue text
overrides pink text because it's lower
now there's another way to override
styles and that's with IDs so I'm gonna
add an ID to this h1 here it's gonna be
ID equals and we're gonna have an ID
name called orange text and now I'm
gonna put the ID style right above the
pink text because when you're styling
IDs it doesn't matter the order doesn't
matter if it's above or below the other
styles because IDs are even more
specific let me show you what I mean so
remember in starting with a dial gonna
start with a hash sign or pound sign and
I'm going to put orange text and here
we're gonna put color orange and now I'm
going to show the browser here and we'll
refresh and you can see it's orange text
because IDs are specific you are only
supposed to have one ID per page so
orange text should only be on this
element whereas classes you would put on
multiple elements IDs you only apply to
one element so IDs are more specific
than classes
and here's another way to override class
declarations with inline Styles inline
styles are gonna be more specific than
all these other ways of styling text I'm
gonna go right into this element here
input style equals and then I'm just
going to change the color to white you
can write this just as you would write
your CSS above but right in line now I'm
going to open up the browser here and
then you should be able to see that text
is white so that's even more specific
you've learned many ways to override CSS
and get even more and more specific
starting at the body then pink text and
blue text and orange text we've learned
many ways but now I'm about to tell you
about the most powerful method of all
how you can show something is super
important let me show you that now if
you remember this pink text has been
overridden many times but now we're
going to show that this is very
important I'm going to use the
exclamation point and then the word
important
so using this exclamation point
important after a style means it's the
most important style you should
definitely apply this style so let's see
what that looks like and now it is pink
hello world is now pink
so far we've been coloring things using
the actual color names like for instance
black or orange or green or blue but
there's a way to get even more specific
using hex codes hex codes are six
hexadecimal digits that represent colors
so you can represent any color on the
spectrum using a hex code so I'm going
to change this instead of black I'm
going to put the hexadecimal for black
which is just zero zero zero zero zero
zero so the first two zeros are the red
the second two zeros are the green and
the third two zeros are blue but since
it's black it's just zero for every
single one so let's see what that looks
like in the browser and it's still black
[Music]
hex codes can be used to create over 16
million different colors and that's what
we're going to do here we're gonna put
in the right hex codes for these colors
so the hex for red is going to be
they're always going to start with the
hash marker pound key and I'm just gonna
put ff0000 and then for a green we're
gonna do the hash mark and it's going to
be 0 0 FF 0 0 and then for Dodger blue
text now I don't have these memorize I'm
actually just reading them off Mohs
you're not it's gonna be hard to
memorize 16 million different
combinations for colors so usually
you're gonna look these up somewhere
there's a lot of websites and a lot of
other resources to find the appropriate
hex codes for different colors so for
the orange text it's gonna be FFA 5 0 0
and let's open up the browser and see
what this looks like if i refresh this
and now we see all the different colors
some hex codes can be shortened remember
they're usually six digits long
but sometimes the hex codes have three
sets of two of the same digits for
instance red text the hex code is
normally ff0000 you can see that the
first two digits are F the second two
digits are 0 and the third two digits
are 0 so whenever there's 3 sets of 2 we
can shorten this by just doing one
number one digit for each so f 0 is 0 so
this F will be expanded to FF this would
be expanded to 0 0 and this would be
expanded to 0 0 for future for future
text we can do F 0 F for the cyan text
we can do 0 FF and then then for the
green text we can do 0 F 0 so let's open
the browser and see if we got those
colors and it worked
besides using hex values to represent
colors you can also represent colors
using RGB values so that would be like
this instead of this hex value you would
put RGB and then there's going to be
three numbers each number is going to be
between 0 and 255 I'll just use 255 3
times here and then if we show this in
the browser 255 255 255 is white but for
this challenge we're going to change
change it to black so black is just
going to be zero zero zero zero zero
zero for black and if i refresh we'll
see that it's changed to black
you can make just as many colors using
RGB as you can make with hex so I'm
going to make all these colors with RGB
instead of hex so for the red text it's
just going to be RGB and then the first
number is always red and then we have
the green and then we have the blue so
for red it's all red no green no blue
you can kind of mix to decide how much
you want to beat color color with RGB
and you can really do the same thing
with hex as well so for orchid text
let's do RGB and this is going to be 2
18 1 12 and then 2 1 4 I don't actually
have all these memorize I'm just reading
them off here and to make this even
easier I'm going to do some copying and
pasting so we're going to have the
Sienna text and the blue text Sienna is
going to be 160 and then 1 1 Oh
82 and then we're going to do 45 and
then for blue this is going to be an
easy one because we just have 0 0 255
and now let's look at the browser to see
what that's going to look like there are
our colors
look at this sweet penguin created only
with CSS and HTML we're not going to go
into exactly how to create this you can
look at the code to find out yourself
but this is all about showing CSS
variables so here right here our CSS
variables so the penguin skin black
belly gray B yellow you can see they're
used here like here background we have
the VAR and then here the parentheses
two dashes
penguin - skin and gray so this would be
the backup color right here but this
would be we would try to use this
variable if we can't use this variable
we go to the backup but right now I'm
going to show you how just changing
these variable colors will change
everything every time those variables
are used so I'm going to change this
black to gray I'm gonna change this gray
to white and I'm gonna change the yellow
to orange and then if I just refresh
here you can see our pin 1 is a
completely different color now is it was
super easy we only had to change in one
spot and it changed everywhere in the
code
in the last challenge we were introduced
to variables now we'll go over them some
more and learn about them in more detail
so to create a variable we're gonna do
it right here so we're gonna create a
penguin skin variable so they always
start with two dashes and then we just
do we put the name here which is going
to be penguin skin now we're going to be
able to use this variable anywhere
throughout the code this is just going
to be gray so now anywhere we use this
penguin skin variable it's gonna be
replaced with gray in the code
so in the last challenge we created this
variable penguin skin gray now we're
going to use it so to use a variable you
just put var and in parentheses you put
the variable name let me show you here
for this background I'm going to put var
and then parentheses and then I'm just
gonna put it - desc penguin skin and
then that's the variable we're gonna use
the same variable in multiple places so
I'm just gonna copy this and we'll paste
it here and then I'll paste it here and
then if i refresh it's great oh there's
a wing let's see we have to replace one
more spot okay
let's replace there and refresh and now
everything that supposed to be gray is
now gray so now we had to replace all
these spots this time but from now on
whenever we want to change the color of
the penguin skin we only have to change
in one spot that's the great thing about
variable
variables can have fallback values
attached these are used if for some
reason the variable won't work it could
be because someone is using an older
browser that doesn't use CSS variables
or maybe just a variable name is spelled
wrong so that's what's happening here
CSS pinguin that spelled wrong but to
show that that's just to show these
fallback values so what I'm going to do
is just add the word black here and then
here I can add the word black and now
let's just refresh this and you can see
it's using the fallback value because it
cannot find the pinguin skin because it
spelled wrong here
variables are available inside the
element in which you create it so we
have these variables here the reason why
they work in the other parts of the
penguin is because everything is within
the penguin element like the right cheek
left cheek belly these are all within
the penguin element sometimes in order
to make variables available anywhere in
a document you can declare the variables
inside a root element you can think of
the root element as a container for your
entire HTML document in the same way
that an HTML element is a container for
the body element so anytime you create a
variable within the root element they're
gonna be available throughout the whole
page so that's what we're gonna do here
so I'm gonna make a variable named
penguin belly and then this is going to
be pink so we can already see that it's
used in these spots here so you can when
belly is used here pin when bellies use
here so it's using these two different
places and but just making it here
within the root we're gonna be able to
use it everywhere else so let me refresh
the page and you can see that it's pink
in both places
so variables are cleared with Andrew to
apply to the whole page but you can
overwrite those within a specific
element so down here I'm going to
overwrite penguin belly so penguin belly
and this is now going to be white so if
i refresh the page it's white now
Media queries can be used to change
variables media queries make different
CSS apply depending on the size of the
screen so here's a media query for max
width 300 pixels so we can make
variables that only apply when the max
width is 350 pixels so let's try
changing the size so now the penguin
size will be 200 pixels and we're also
gonna try changing the skin so penguin
skin with this media query will be black
so now when you change the size of the
browser I'll let me refresh again it
will change the variables
[Music]
time to create our first CSS grid you
can turn any HTML element into a grid
container by setting its display
property to grid so we have this HTML
element container and then here is the
CSS for that we are going to set the
display property property to grid and
this will give us the ability to use the
other properties associated with CSS
grid so I'm just gonna put display red
and we're done so it doesn't do anything
quite yet because we haven't updated any
of the other properties yet but we'll do
that in later challenges
now we need to start defining the
structure of the grid we'll start with
adding some columns using grid template
columns so I'm going to do that now and
show you how to solve this challenge I'm
going to type in grid template columns
and after grid template columns we're
gonna put the width of each column so
the number the number of numbers we put
here are the number of columns we're
gonna have three columns so we're gonna
have three numbers and all of them are
going to be 100 pixels wide so I just
have to put 100 pixels three times and
now if i refresh the page here you'll
see that we have three columns
so here we have grid template columns
which we already learned about which
sets the number of columns now we want
to set the exact number of rows right
now the rows are just determined
automatically but if we know exactly how
many rows we want we can use grid
template rows so to solve this challenge
we just have to add grid template rows
and then just like grid template columns
the number of numbers are the number of
rows and each number is how tall each
one will be so I'm gonna put 50 pixels
50 pixels so we'll have two rows or each
50 pixels high so if i refresh that it
looks pretty similar because that was
very close to what the default was but
we just solved it
you can use CSS grid units to change the
size of columns and rows you can use
pixels and M's but you can also use
things like F R which sets the column or
row to a fraction of the the available
space see this how we have five
different columns and they're all
different sizes well we have this code
here so you can see the first column is
auto that's the one here and that sets
the column to the size of the space so
it just is just big enough for that one
to fit in there and then the second
column is 50 so this column with the two
is 50 pixels wide with the three we have
10% so this three is ten percent of the
available section from the whole
container this is three percent of the
whole container and now we have the two
F are on one fr that's columns four and
five so the last two columns the
remaining space is divided into three
sections because two plus one is three
two of the sections are allocated to the
fourth column and one to the fifth
column we're gonna make a grid with
three columns instead of all five of
these we're going to specify three of
them so the first one is going to be one
fr and then we're gonna have 100 pixels
and then two fr so let's see what that
looks like when i refresh the page here
so we can see we have three columns the
middle column is always staying at 100
pixels no matter how wide but the first
and third column will change because of
the fr units here
you can see here in these columns
there's no gap between the columns these
are split up right against each other
sometimes you want to gap between the
columns so you use grid column gap I'm
gonna show you how to do that right now
and show you how to solve this challenge
so it's gonna be grid column gap and
then we set how many pixels we want in
between each column in this case we're
going to put 20 pixels so if i refresh
here we should see space in between each
column
in the last challenge we learned about
grid column gap you probably won't be
surprised to learn that there's also a
grid row gap so it works just the same
but grid
row gap and it'll make a gap between the
rows this case will put five pixels if i
refresh here you can see that there is a
space in between the rows here
the grid gap property is a shorthand
property for using the grid row gap and
grid column gap properties all at once
if you just put one number it will put
the same gap on the rows and columns if
you use two numbers the first number
will be rows the second number will be
columns so I'm going to just do the two
numbers here so I'm going to do grid gap
and then the first number is going to be
10 pixels for the rows and the second
number is gonna be 20 pixels for the
columns if i refresh this here we can
see that there's the ten pixels in
between and then there's the 20 pixels
for the columns here
the grid column property is used to set
how many columns a grid item will take
up
now here's a 3x3 grid and there's these
hypothetical lines that you don't see
but they exist in between the grids and
they're numbered one you can see in this
example for a 3x3 grids there's 4 lines
1 2 3 4 so for the grid column property
to set how many columns and item is
going to take up you're gonna specify
the beginning line and the ending line
so if you wanted to take up two columns
the first two columns you would specify
line 1 and then line 3 because it would
start at line 1 and it would end at line
3 let me show you what that would look
like so for instance if we were going to
set this item 5 to set to take up the
first two columns it would be like this
grid column and then we would put 1/3
because it would start at the first line
and end at the third line for this
challenge though we are going to make
the grid take up the final two columns
so it's gonna start at 2 and in that 4
so if we refresh that we should see that
this fifth element starts at 2 and then
it ends at 4 just like that
we learned how to make grid items
consume multiple columns we can also do
the same thing with rows
it's basically the same thing so in sort
of grid column is gonna be grid row and
then for this challenge we have to make
it take up the last two rows so the same
as before I'm going to put 2/4 because
if you look on the diagram the last two
rows are these two rows and it's going
to start the two line and end at the
four line so let's refresh the page here
and you'll see that's taking up the last
two rows of this section here
in CSS grid each box is considered a
cell so each of these colored boxes on
screen are considered different cells if
we use justify self we can justify and
align the content within the cells by
default the property is a value of
stretch which will make the content fill
the whole width of the cell but for this
challenge we're going to try a different
a different property so I'll do justify
self and instead of setting it to
stretch which is the default I'm going
to set it to Center we can also do start
or end but if we set the center you'll
see that this has been centered within
the cell just like that
in the last challenge we used justify
self which aligns horizontally now we're
going to align an item vertically using
align self it works pretty much the same
way so I'm going to put a line self and
then I'm going to set this to end so now
if we refresh you'll see that this
aligns vertically to the bottom of the
cell
if you want all your items in your grid
to share the same alignment you can use
justify items on the parent container it
uses all the same values that we saw
before
so we'll put justify items and then I'll
just set this to be Center if we refresh
we'll see everything has been centered
[Music]
we saw that justified items aligns all
items horizontally aligned items aligns
all items vertically again you put on
the parent container so put a line items
and I'll set this to end to set so all
of them align at the end of each cell so
we see they all go to the bottom which
is the end
here we've created an area template the
cells have been grouped together using a
custom name you'll see when you look at
the rows and columns there's three
columns and 3 rows or nine cells total
and that's how many words you'll see
here so each set of three words in
quotation marks is a row so that's the
first row second row third row and you
can see each word corresponds to a cell
in this layout here so you can see the
first three are now designated headers
and then we have an advert and then to
contents and then the last three are the
footer cells you can use a period to
designate an empty salma grid and that's
what we'll do for this challenge so
instead of the word advert here I'm just
going to put a period and that
designates it as an empty cell
we saw how to define our template areas
here in the last challenge now we'll
learn how to place items in a specific
spot in the grid area so if we want to
set item 5 to be in a specific spot
we'll use the grid area property so a
grid area and then we just put one of
our custom names that we defined below
for instance if we set this to header
and I refresh here you'll see the number
5 has popped out of its normal location
and fills up the entire header it fills
up the entire header because there are 3
items in the header and there's only
only item 5 is set to header so it fills
up the whole header for this challenge
however we're going to put it in the
footer so I'll just change this name to
footer and if we refresh again you'll
see that the item 5 takes up the entire
footer
you can create grid areas without a
template you'll notice here that we no
longer have our template code here but
I'm going to show you how to create a
grid area so st. before we throw a grid
area but instead of saying the template
name I'm going to put some numbers I'll
do 1 / 1 / 2 / 4 now these use the same
type of numbers that we talked about
before if you look at this chart here
it's almost like setting coordinates on
a graph the first two numbers are the
start coordinate and the last two
numbers are the end coordinate so the
first two numbers would be the
horizontal line to start with in the
vertical line to start with so for one
one it would start in this top corner
here and then you'll see that the second
two numbers are 2 4 so 2 4 means it's
going to end at the second horizontal
line here's 2 and then here's 4 it's
gonna end at the 4th vertical line so 1
1 2 4 would start at this point and end
at this point so that would just take up
the entire top row so let's see what
that looks like I'll refresh and we'll
see that the 5 takes up the entire top
row now we'll make some slight changes
to this to solve the challenge so the
numbers we're going to use our 3 1 or 4
so if you look on here 3 1 would be
right here
four four would be right here so now I
should take up the bottom row let's
refresh and you'll see five takes up the
bottom row
if you want to repeat the same size row
or column many times you can use the
repeat function if you see right here we
have the same size row repeated three
times one F R 1 F R 1 F R we can use the
repeat function to repeat that three
times here's another way you can use the
repeat function let me put it in here so
to use the repeat function you start
with the word repeat and then in
parenthesis we're gonna pass in
something first the number of times you
want to repeat so in this case I'm gonna
pass in the number two you could use 75
50 100 however many times you want this
to repeat now we could put one size to
repeat the same size over and over or we
can put in any number of sizes so I'm
going to put one fr and then 50 pixels
so it's going to repeat that two times
and then you can even add other sizes
afterwards so I'm going to put 20 pixels
let me show you how this would be
calculated I'm going to copy this and
just paste it in here now normally you
would never have grid template rows
twice in a row
I'm just using this as an example so
when this calculates out it would look
like this I'll copy this because it's
going to be on there two times and now
you'll see one fr 50 pixels 1 if R 50
pixels 20 pixels so this with the repeat
function would calculate out to this
let's back up a little bit I'm gonna
undo some of the things I put in here to
go back to what the code look like
initially and now we're actually going
to make a change to the grid template
columns see how it says 1 fr 3 times
let's use the repeat function to do the
same thing so I'm going to do repeat and
then it pass in 3 and then 1 fr so now
if i refresh we should see no changes it
looks exactly the same because this is
equivalent to what we already had
you can also set the size of a row or
column using the min/max function the
min/max function takes two arguments the
first number is the smallest size that
the row or column can be and then the
second number is the largest size a row
or column can be so let me show you how
this works and show you how to solve
this challenge I'm gonna replace this
second number and the repeat function
with the min/max function which will
pass in two arguments first will be 90
pixels that will be the minimum amount
that the wrote that this column can be
and then the second number is going to
be 1fr which would be the max amount
that the column can be so if I just
refresh the page here you can see how it
changes depending on the size of the the
frame here
we saw already that in the repeat
function the first argument you pass in
is the number of times you want this to
repeat so this is going to repeat three
times you can also use autofill so if
you use autofill it's going to
automatically insert as many rows or
columns of your desired size as possible
depending on the size of the container
so let's see what happens I'm going to
refresh the page here and then we'll see
that this changes depending on the size
of the container you can see the
difference between container one and
container to container two at the bottom
has just repeating three and then the
top one has repeat autofill so you can
see how they behave differently
depending on the size
we talked about autofill this one right
here now we're going to talk about
autofit it's very similar I think the
best way to show you the difference
would be to actually show you what what
effect it has on this browser here so
this first one is set to autofill for
this challenge we have to set the second
one to auto sit so I'm going to put auto
fit and now let's just refresh the
browser and we'll can see how they're
very very similar but not quite you can
see they work very similar but you see
that auto fit always make sure that they
fit the entire length of the container
while auto sill doesn't necessarily
needed to fit the entire length of the
container they still keep repeating as
much as you need to but it's just
whether it's gonna stretch or not
Media queries can be used along with
template areas to make responsive
layouts let's look at the page right now
see when I change the size it will
change how things are laid out on the
screen with the header that advert the
content so you can see how that works
here here is the default the default one
is right here with and the default would
be then the smaller size however we also
have this media query when the min width
is 300 pixels so when it's over 300
pixels we're going to change the
template so you'll see here there's just
four areas header advert content footer
here each row has the advert on the side
and then either has the header the
content or footer you can see that when
you change the size of the the window
size let's do one more
to solve this challenge when the min
width is 400 pixels we want the header
to be along the all the top so I'm gonna
put header I know the change word advert
the header and we want the footer to be
long the full bottom admin with 400
pixels so I'm going to put footer here
and now if i refresh we'll see that
there's three different sizes we can do
so here you can see the header on the
top and bottom and the advert in the
middle now the average stretches all the
way from the top to bottom and then the
third size would be everything right on
top of each other
you can have grids within grids
this item three right here corresponds
to the paragraph one and two on the page
so we're gonna change item three into a
grid so I'll do a display bread now I'll
set the grid template columns to set
what the columns are going to be and
we'll use auto and then 1fr so let's see
what happens if i refresh you'll see
that this it now takes up the whole
space here and there's a grid within the
grid
[Music]
flexbox is used to position CSS elements
in a flexible way so we're going to be
talking about flexbox in this section to
use flex on an element we're going to
have to set the display to flex that's
what I'll do here display flex so now
we've set this boxing painter to display
flex and you can see it now sets the
boxes right next to each other on the
page
throughout this section we will be using
flex to style this tweet so to get ready
we're gonna have to add display flex to
a lot of the elements so let's add it to
the header display flex when you're
using flexbox you have to use display
flex on a lot of different things so I'm
just going to copy this and we have on
the header we have it on the profile
name we have it on the follow button we
have on this h3 h4 we have it on the
footer and we have on the stats so now
we have flex box everywhere we want to
have it and you can see it's already
made some changes to what our page looks
like
after we add display flex to an element
it becomes a flex container and this
makes it possible to align any children
of the element into rows or columns
using the Flex Direction property the
default to flex Direction is row but you
can also set it to column or row reverse
or column reverse so for this challenge
we are going to set this box container
element to have a flex direction so it
will put flex direction and it will I'll
set it to row reverse now let's update
the page and see what happens and you
can see everything has been reversed
now we'll apply the flex direction
property to create rows in our tweet so
the both the header and the footer have
child elements that could be arranged as
rows so that's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna use flex direction here in the
header direction and then set this to
row now I'll just copy this and then I'm
going to paste it down at the footer so
now they both have flex direction row if
i refresh you'll see that nothing has
changed that's because row is the
default setting for Flex direction but
we'll be making more changes in future
challenges
we saw how to use flex direction to
create rows
now we'll do it to create columns it's
pretty straightforward
we'll just set flex direction to column
and now we should see a change when we
refresh see Row is the default so when
we set flex direction to column
it updates to columns
you can see in this tweet that the name
Quincey Larson and his Twitter handle
appear right next to each other these
would look good stacked on top of each
other this is the perfect time to use
flex direction column so let's go down
to the profile name section here because
the name and the twitter handle are all
wrapped in the profile name class so
let's add flex direction and then set it
to column now let's refresh and see what
that looks like okay much better
you can align elements using the justify
content property this diagram represents
a flex container and this is a row
remember they're either going to be in
rows or columns and this represents a
row with two items you can see the first
item here and the second item here now
there are several options for how to
space the Flex items along the line that
is the main axis you can see the main
axis goes straight through like this if
there is a column the main axis will go
up and down instead of left and right
but one of the most commonly used ways
to space the Flex items is justify
Content Center which aligns all the Flex
items to the center inside the Flex
container also there's a flex start
which will align the items to the start
of the Flex container over on the left
side here for a row this pushes the ions
to the left of the container but a comma
for a column is gonna push the items to
the top and then flex end is over on the
right side it pushes the things to the
right space between will align items to
the center of the main axis and there
will be extra space placed between the
items now the first and last ions are
pushed to the very edge of the Flex
container space around it's similar to
space between but the first and last
items are not locked to the edges of the
container and the space is distributed
around all the items so let's see this
in practice for this challenge we're
just going to try one of these so I am
going to put the property justify
content here and then I'm going to set
it to Center so let's see what happens
on our page see now everything's
centered and how its justified now I
would recommend trying some of the other
options on your own
now we're going to use the justify
content property in the tweet in bed so
I'll show you how to do that challenge
right now in this profile class here for
the style we're going to put justify
content here and we can set this to any
of the options from the last challenge
I'm going to use flex in but you can use
something else and still passed the
challenge now as i refresh the page look
at this name here it's just going to
move down very slightly so you're going
to look closely to see the difference so
if i refresh here it goes to the bottom
of this row here
the align items property is similar to
the justify content property the justify
content property aligns along this main
axis right here but the the align items
property aligned along the cross axis
and these axes are opposite if you're
using a column instead of a row where
the cross axis would be back and forth
left and right for a column and the main
axis would be up-and-down for a column
but this diagram shows a row and the
different values for align items are
pretty much the same as they are for
justified content you have the flex star
flex in center stretch and baseline so
the stretch and baseline are the
different ones the stretch will stretch
the items to fill the Flex container and
baseline will align the items to their
baselines so let's see an example of
this in our code here we are going to
add something to our box container here
so I'm going to put a line items and
then I'll set it to Center and we should
be able to see what that does here so
let me refresh the page you see these
have been aligned to the center of our
page here
now we'll use the align items property
in the tweet embed so to solve this
challenge we're just going to apply it
to two different sections here in this
follow button class will put align items
and then we'll set to center and I'm
just going to copy this line because
we're going to use the same line below
right in the h3 and h4 and now if i
refresh the page you'll see that things
are aligned in the center now it doesn't
show up too much because you can see
this is just moved down slightly the
movement was very slight but it is
aligned now
by default a flex container will fit all
flex items together you can see here
that all these colored boxes are in one
row here but if you use the Flex wrap
property it tells CSS to wrap items so
it just means the extra ions move to a
new row or column so I'm going to show
you how to solve this challenge here by
adding Flex wrap and I'm going to set
this to ramp another setting you can use
is wrap reverse you can see now it wraps
to the next line
the Flex rink property applies to flex
items instead of a flex container it
allows an item to shrink if the Flex
container is too small so I'm going to
apply the Flex shrink property to both
of these items here box 1 and box 2 like
this this will solve this the challenge
here it's going to set you always have
to set a number so I'm going to set this
one to one and then I'll set the next
one could too so these numbers shrink in
relation to each other so if the second
one is 2 that means that this box 2 will
be 2 times as small as box 1 that has a
shrink value of 1 so let's refresh and
see what happens you can see that the
red box is 2 times as small as the blue
box
the Flex Grill property is basically the
opposite of the Flex shrink property the
Flex shrink property controls the size
of the items when the container shrinks
but the Flex grow property controls the
size of the items when the parent can
that when the parent container expands
right now the website doesn't know how
to render this HTML here and the CSS
because we need to add a flex grill
property so let's do this the box 1 and
box 2 so we'll do Flex grow and then
output a 1 just like Flex rink you're
gonna put a number and now instead of
this being 2 times smaller I'm going to
put 2 again for box 2 instead of it
being 2 times smaller it's gonna be 2
times bigger so I'm gonna set this to 2
and now this should know how to render
if i refresh and you can see box 2 is 2
times larger because we added flex grow
the flex basis property specifies the
initial size of the item before CSS
makes adjustments with Flex shrink or
flex grow so we're gonna see how that
works here we're going to set a specific
size with pixels m's or percentages or
Auto so let's add that to box 1 in box 2
I'm going to put Flex ASIS and you can
see you can even see box 1 our box 2
until we add this so the first one's
gonna be 10 a.m. and then I'll do Flex
basis and this one will do 20 EMS and if
i refresh we should see it on here okay
so now it works
the flex property
is a shortcut to set the Flex Gro Flex
rink and flex basis properties all at
once let me show you an example with the
default property settings so the default
property settings of Flex
are 0 1
Auto so the first number is the Flex
trow number the second number is the
Flex drink number and then we have the
Flex basis here so for this challenge
we're gonna go off of the default and I
am going to set the first flex row to
two and then I'll set the Flex rink to
two and I'll set the Flex basis to 150
pixels
now this wings similar for box two
I'm going to also set the Flex property
so it's going to be 1 1 and then 150
pixels so let me show that in the
browser and see what that's like now we
can change the size and you can see when
it's small the red box is bigger but
when the browser gets bigger the blue
box is bigger so because of how we set
the properties at the at the 300 pixels
lines it's going to change which one's
getting bigger and which one's getting
smaller
the order property can be used to
rearrange items by default they just
appear in the order that they're there
so the blue box box one appears first
and then the red box box to appear
second but we can change that what's the
order property so for order I'm going to
put this first box to have the order of
two and then I'm going to set the second
box to have an order of one so we should
see the red and blue flip pick places
when I press refresh and that's what we
see
the aligned self property will align
each item individually we already talked
about the a line items property which
you set on the parent container when you
set and align items on the parent
container every item within that
container is aligned in the same way but
if we use align self we use it on the
individual item and we can set each one
differently
it will override any value set by the
aligned items property so for this
challenge let's set some align items or
align self for these items so I'll do
align itself and then you can use any
value that you can also use in the O
line items property in this case I'm
going to put Center for this one and
then down here align self
I'll put flex and another odd option we
flex start so let's refresh and then we
can see here that this blue box is
centered and then this red box is the
end or goes to the bottom of the row
here well thanks for watching the CSS
course don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good